what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg and John here today what did we
just watch John we just watched Guardians of
the Galaxy the first one no volume three you
just watched Gardens gossip on three right through
those doors right there here's what I'm gonna ask
you guys to do up front please go ahead and leave
a like because we always risk getting kicked out
of the what's happened several times got a lot
of feelings and thoughts on this one and before
watching it uh the journey over the past week
has been I watched Guardians of the Galaxy one
again I rewatched Guardians 2. and honestly
Guardians 2 went up a lot in my book since
the last time I talked to death about a recent
livestream at David koi and then I watched I I
am Groot and I watch Infinity war end game and
the holiday special because I just wanted like
the complete package and to see how this story
of the Guardians really does conclude I am sad
to say bye to them so with that in mind we got
a special sponsor for today's video that's also
really going to come in handy because right
now Vimeo is charging us a ton at our patreon
right now so we're gonna roll this out real quick
thank you to Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy for
sponsoring this video because I was ecstatic
to shout them out and you want to know why
I already owned the game within the first week of
getting my PS5 a friend of my wife and I gifted us
with this video game so it was literally the
very first game I played on the PlayStation
5 and it's a genuine blast do keep in mind the
game is also available on Xbox consoles and PC
now I have said it many times right here on this
very Channel Guardians of the Galaxy is one of my
all-time favorite MCU movies so like many of you
I am sad to see it ending with volume 3. however
if you want to keep the adventure going with
the Guardians this game is genuinely a great
way to keep that feeling alive it's a single
player story driven action adventure game but
it also won best narrative at the game awards in
2021 so you know what's good now I'm guilty of
not having read the Guardians Comics only seen
the movies so this was a unique way to live in
the cosmic comic book world with the team while
getting familiar but different shades of them
throughout the Adventure Learn to work together
and you know of course help save the Galaxy along
the way and something that I really wanted to
mention to you guys is that while you play a
Star-Lord vast majority of the game you actually
play alongside the other guy Guardians as well so
with that there's this massive amount of back and
forth dialogue that is present for what I think is
like the almost the entirety of the game which
makes it feel all the more lived in especially
because everyone has such a unique distinct voice
and all the Voice work is also great and a lot of
the time you get dialogue choices on which way
you want to take the conversation so it makes
for a lot of fun role-playing but sometimes it
actually makes an impact on a decision from a
guardian later on another thing I really want to
make clear too is that while you can upgrade your
abilities as Star-Lord as you go along you also
play alongside the other Guardians so while you're
playing you can actually upgrade their abilities
as well and instruct them to use them on command
the worlds are really cool they have a lot of
great outfits for the Guardians inspired by the
comics and the MCU as well the creature designs
are as cosmically weird and welcoming as you'd
hoped for and the story itself is a lot of fun
but like you'd want it also has a lot of heart
and oh yeah the soundtrack they have this amazing
soundtrack it's fantastic epic orchestral score to
classic 80s rock tracks and they have an original
Rock album created just for this game so yeah guys
this game gets a very high glowing recommendation
for me if you're interested you can go ahead
hit up our Link in the description box and pin
comment thank you again for sponsoring this video
alright so if you've seen the trailers regards
the Galaxy 3 they actually really don't give
away what the plot of the movie is so we're not
going to give away what the exact plot of the
film is but you get some teases of it involving
high evolutionary as this person who is the one
responsible for creating rocket you get a sense
of a lot of peril and danger throughout but you
also get a sense that the movie will probably
be very emotional a lot more in that department
than the previous two Guardians films look I'm
going to keep it real simple and straightforward
for you guys we are going to be doing a live
stream spoiler talk most of what I want to say
is gonna be reserved for that discussion because
there is so much in here so much so much in here
that I don't want to ruin for anyone or even
really allude to honestly because they don't
even give away with the exact plot of the movie
is but the exact plot is a very personal plot I
thought this was the exact film it needed to be I
thought it was a perfect conclusion where would I
rank it I have no no idea where I would rank it
just yet I thought this was a strong film that
just got better as it kept going does it have
a couple of spots that I I wonder if they would
get worse or better in a re-watch maybe that is
not my takeaway with this movie right now I have
left this movie feeling content I feel content
with what happened here I just feel like at ease
with knowing like wow I I really love this film
going to a little bit more specifics but what are
your quick thoughts John yeah I know I'm I'm left
with a similar feeling kind of kind of the blend
of catharsis you get after a good cry a good
laugh and a fight propulsive and there is so
much to talk about but to me it was just a grand
and emotional cathartic and and really propulsive
experience like they they really hit the ground
running and anything I you know might have griped
about in part two like you said got better for
me there and here I thought it builds really well
on top of everything that has come before it used
all the history yeah I didn't even know quite what
I wanted or expected going into this but coming
out of it I think they really achieved something
special and it is two James Gunn's credit he
really does seem like one of the few MCU directors
who is able to like transcend and put his own
unique stamp on something there's like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe then there's James Gunn's
movies yeah right and they have their own visual
Flint like they fit into but they have their
own visual Flair their own tone their own humor
their own style and he definitely got to strut his
weird Aesthetics all over them and he goes darker
this time gets bold with the way they execute
things one thing I really want to say John do it
something that you don't really feel a lot in some
of these Marvel properties as of late yeah there
are some real stakes in tension here 100 there's
there's quite a few like it really earns the
Applause because they get you wrapped up in the
harrowing aspect of these things oh my God who's
gonna die what's gonna happen like it just it just
keeps you going the whole time the lives really
feel at stake in this movie in a way that is very
satisfying to me the standout performers they're
all so good in this they're all it's hard to start
with one good uh like they all get a chance to
shine but Rocket Raccoon and Star-Lord would be
the highlights for me like it's it's their films
more than anyone else is here I don't want that
to sound like the other ones don't get a chance to
shine no cause The Supporting Cast is so strong in
doing what they're there to do like from watching
the holiday special and the fact that they carry
over mantis and drax's relationship into here and
then explore that even more and get more later
semantics I thought was excellent but rocket
you truly get his origin in this movie you know
you've probably seen some social media reactions
there is such a tragedy to his backstory there
is so much life and nuance and the movie has a
lot of body horror but it's a lot but in the kind
of body horror that I like the most which is not
like oh look how gross it is body Horror in the
sense of like an emotionally tragic way it serves
the characters and the themes so much uh but I
mean there's a couple of moments like wow that's
graphic it reminded me of photographer I was like
I can't believe they put that in this movie yeah
it's lucky that we're in a Sci-Fi world with
all that stuff but it reminded me of freaks at
times in that way where the point is you're seeing
something and you're initially supposed to recoil
but then you'd see the person inside of the Visage
yeah that's another place for the imagination for
the design to go crazy but also ways to strike
you like you said emotionally it's interesting
like we're in Phase five now so much of phase
four dealt with overcoming trauma and overcome
and dealing with grief and this movie carries that
but in a very unique way especially through the
lens of rocket and Star-Lord Chris Pratt give his
best work here out of any of the Guardians movies
as much as he was kind of like a little bit of
like a doofus and lost some of the coolness as
it kind of went he's powerful in this movie he is
really really good like this movie reminded me of
like oh yeah this is what makes him a star
see that's been I don't mean no pun intended
literally I mean like in the Celebrity Status to
Chris prattley they dial back a lot of that doofus
stuff and really cool and dramatically engaging
he gives a powerful performance here I go back
and forth on him sometimes it's just a Hollywood
personality but re-watching the first one I was
like man this is the Chris Pratt I really like
and now watching this one I was like this is that
but also yeah with all the weight and emotion and
the maturity that the characters had to go through
over this journey and he really carries that in
a way that doesn't like overshadow everything but
it is impressive and it is touching and they don't
undermine it with humor you really see him at like
how he has become a leader Adam Warlock as seen
in the trailer here he's got a great introduction
it would be a spoiler for me to tell you what they
do with him I really think as a matter of fact we
bumped into a couple of people who our first time
meeting them there's the first thing they brought
up with us I think there will be some debates
on the handling of Adam Warlock overall I did
like him there are a couple of things where I'm
like this is great and works for the Guardians
movie I wonder how people will overall react for
people who know or are aware of Adam or come into
the movie for Adam yeah like it works great for
guardians but there are some choices that they
make where I go huh I wonder how that's going to
overall go down with people yeah for sure but Will
Poulter still does a great job regardless well
Poulter still shows up his introduction is really
really strong yeah uh very very menacing and
intimidating you're like God damn and one of the
top things I was hearing when the movie was done
other than a bunch of Tears around me which was
kind of happening throughout the film oh I feel
like this is a weird thing to say is a relief to
hear a bunch of people talking about the VFX are
awesome in this movie yes they are fantastic VFX
cinematography is excellent in fact I don't want
to go into any details about what the fight scene
entails but it might have one of my favorite fight
scenes I've seen in all of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it was like an unexpected fight that
happened yes and it was an important fight too
but when it happens I was like wow this is real
it earned a really awesome Applause and yeah
we did go to the premiere for this one normally
we don't go to the premieres for them I'm often
kind of wary about crowd influence especially
I've seen that's affect previous reviews for I
wanted to experience with the crowd but I'll say
like this crowd was for the most part actually
not a cheering crowd like we were wrapped with
attention it was one of those movies where like
does it have jokes yeah it's got the jokes at the
same time I wasn't even really laughing a lot but
I don't mean that in an insulting way I was just
so like transported during my experience with this
movie A jokes would happen or I would just be in
my head going that's a funny joke that's so funny
Marvel humor problems it just feel just feel
like how the characters all talk and the way
they acknowledge some of the humor of previous
films like a lot of people have complained about
Drax and how they just really dumbed them up they
really acknowledge that I really feel like James
Gunn has listened and attuned and I really think
it is a perfect conclusion to it all again great
soundtracks choices terrific sounds perfect
soundtrack choices uh nebula Karen gillen's
best work absolutely and not not of all time
I would say but out of playing nebula yeah I
I want to go into specifics I do uh but
I'm refraining from it what I want to
just communicate to you guys is really just
the emotion I feel right now which is It's A
Beautiful film guys it's it's beautiful on
the outside also just what it's got going
on underneath the surface It's A Beautiful film
well yeah it carries on those themes from phase
four of the trauma and of the messiness but it
also kind of arcs into a certain kind of closure
and a certain kind of acceptance and a stepping
into healing in a way I know people will debate
but I thought a very striking and a very uh just
compelling villain in the high evolutionary and
all that comes with him is so unhinged but in a
way where you completely feel the reality of who
the character is though he'd be you know Larger
than Life yeah I would say that there are times
where I felt that it would occasionally go to
too much of like it just yells a lot sometimes
it kind of comes across that way like I I wonder
if it'll still feel that way to me on a re-watch
but there were times where it was okay I kind of
feel like a lot of what you're giving this guy to
do is just really just yell there yeah there's
certainly that maniacal like my Creations blah
blah but I thought he handled that well and
they do something different with the like At
first as the movie's going you're kind of going
is this going down to the generic path you kind of
expect to do there are certain turns and moments
that yeah are predictable but I think what you
said about the word catharsis is so important
because it earns the moments of still getting
that release you might run into a predictable
moment however the journey to that moment is
so rich and there's something to be said for the
moment of anticipation and then impact because you
want that moment to play out not you'll feel
slighted if it does but they still do things
with high evolutionary that I was not expecting
that I was really impressed by how they decided
to challenge against what you might normally
expect the route to go I would not say it is
cliche they do take some chances and that's why
I would say that there are some really bold moves
of what they do with him God I kind of feel like
Bradley Cooper should get an ostrich even though
really Mr nominate people going back to him
their performances all around if there's
something that we a subject that we missed to
talk about apologies it's just a special camp
for the guardian I I feel like the Guardians of
the Galaxy franchise is something truly special
within the Marvel Cinematic Universe even for
how they carry over an Infinity war and game and
and also Gamora my God we cannot like as always
said to the billions Club so we stopped on Zoe
Saldana I love the fact of how James Gunn really
respected that this was a different Gamora from
endgame specifically dealing with who was Gamora
at the time they plucked her out of there in end
game and who would she be today the choices they
make with her character to be more on the just
to be a different aggressive side to put it
lightly it makes it's a great sci-fi device
because it makes very much sense how and why she
is how she is how she fits into this version of
the Guardians but also how she clashes with them
yeah and then her and she has such a presence like
oh God yeah her and starler have great chemistry
again she's Fierce like when she's with him they
have great like you know friction but but when
she's on her own she's just like Fierce and a
force they managed to create something that to me
feels like it really managed to fuse the unique
aspects of the first one the unique aspects of
the second one adding its own thing to this but
it feels like a complete hole that grew out of
you know what came before it and Groot is lovely
too Groot has a lot of really great moments
in this as well Groot has a moment in here
that people are gonna be talking about you know
even little smaller characters like fraglin and
Cosmo the space dog like there's so many well
utilized great interesting little additions that
have grown again across this familial Katamari
that is the franchise so here's what I'll say guys
um on my first time viewing this right out of
the theater I'm like a 98 sure yeah like a 98
I want to re-watch it to kind of get my feelings
uh real clear on a couple of things that I'm still
unsure how I feel about but for the most part yeah
that's striking amazing and the iMac shots whoa
um we didn't even watch that a real IMAX but it
stands out oh no yeah you can still tell when
it's like switching to the IMAX cameras the scope
plus the way they use so many wide-angle lenses
for all of these which you know are affects
heavy shots and and crazy maneuver like it is
in the age of huge visual effects it still feels
like movie Magic I love it John loves it love it
gonna watch it at least Thrice me at least
two more times in the theaters I just gotta
I gotta leave us down your thoughts Below
on who's your favorite guardian or what
you're expecting this movie or if you happen
to see it what'd you think talk with y'all soon